[Music]  but first america's next top model is  back and only tease cameras were there  at the pink carpet premiere this is all  for you guys their reboot debuts on vh1  this Monday with Rita Ora taking over  Tyra's gig as host Tyra was incredible  she's the queen you know this was never  a feeling anyone's shoes this was a  taking her legacy and really making it  you know our own and with a new panel  you can still expect a few Tyra cameos  which makes judge Ashley Graham very  excited well you know Tyra taught me  best she and I text a lot she doesn't  even know this in my notes I have a Tyra  folder of the memos that she sends me  because they're just encouraging and she  really is an uplifting woman  you